I like my border security like I like my
sex sure I have boundaries but
occasionally I let a Mexican man sneak
in I remember the day the candle shop
burned down everybody just stood around
and saying happy birthday my friend
asked me if you could have any
superpower in the world what would it be
I said Cold War Russia
[Laughter]
when I was in America I really got into
the culture I went into his shop and the
guy said have a nice day and it didn't
so I sued him this farmer came up to me
he said I've got 68 sheep can you round
them up for me how's it short 70 a very
common male fantasies to have two women
at the same time want to cook one to
clean my proctologist just be a
photographer yeah he took x-rays told me
to bend over and say cheese
some gold-plated chains would make a
nice retirement gift for a very very
good slave
I got a you know what man I got a parrot
the parrot talked but it did not say I'm
hungry so it died I had a dream I had a
dream had in a dream that all of babies
prevented by the pill showed up
they were man
there are immigrants that have come to
America stolen jobs and murdered the
local population and we call those
immigrants the founding fathers my
girlfriend's family are quite religious
I remember the first time I went to stay
with her at her parents house and her
dad wouldn't let us sleep together which
is a shame because he's very attractive
is it a boxing club or is it a shoe is
it a Bob Seger or is it a shoe he said a
boxing club or is it a shoe the answer
is it's a torch
I like rice rice is great when you're
hungry and you want 2,000 of something
all right
oh I'm in a sexy girl a few weeks ago
worked in a restaurant making hamburgers
she told me she to make a big boy in
three minutes and a boy pig in two
minutes I went to a proper showbiz party
recently and Brad Pitt was there and
they say never meet your heroes but I
think Brad handled it really well
remember when I was seven my grandmother
said Steven come over here I said what
do you mean
she said you know you're over there and
I'll come over to here I said all right
and then she said here's $10 and don't
tell your mother that I'm giving this to
you and I said it'll cost you more than
that when I was a young boy my dad said
to me too Timmy said you could be
anything you want to be in life the
sky's the limit which made me sad
because it wants to be an astronaut and
I was a very ugly kid every time I oh
man wanted sex my mother showed on my
picture
it's kind of an insane case six thousand
ants dressed up as rice and robbed a
Chinese dress job I don't think they did
it I know a few of them and they
wouldn't do anything I play tennis in LA
I live in Los Angeles I play tennis with
my friend Doug the thing that's
depressing about tennis is no matter how
good I get I'll never be as good as a
wall too euro from the sale of every one
of my DVDs goes to the poor
underprivileged children of Cambodia who
manufacture them
my theory of evolution is that Darwin
was adopted
I was walking by a drycleaner at 3:00
a.m. and the sign said sorry we're
closed you don't have to be sorry it's
3:00 a.m. and you're a dry cleaner it
would be ridiculous for me to expect you
to be open I'm not gonna walk in at
10:00 and say hey man I walked by a
three you guys were closed somebody owes
me an apology
and right you make love to the right
woman Johnny it's beautiful beautiful I
mean the last time I made love to my
wife it was ridiculous
nothing was happening I looked right so
what's the matter can't you think of
anyone either
[Applause]